what's up reject nation so we've been
covering some scary videos weekly has
been a lot of fun it's on the comments a
few people recommended the channel
slapped ham never seen slapped hands
videos before usually one to two times a
day my girlfriend sends me a tick tock
video that makes her laugh I thought
it'd be fun to check out scary tik-tok
videos that can't be explained
let's see what's in store she didn't
anticipate to record one of the scariest
tick top videos that would capture the
site's attention as she records her pets
whoever dogs are calm cool and collected
but one of the pets seems to spotted
something unusual the video shows the
pooch staring down the dark hallway
adjacent to the room however a few
seconds later the woman recording the
video notices something odd as well what
do I suppose it's your wife
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that was dad some seemed like a very
real reaction
it's for her to regain her Valerie's
whimpering to investigate she opens the
closet doors wide revealing nothing out
of the ordinary on the other side of the
doors she gets another shot at moment
later when the bond inside the closet
inexplicably goes out the house she cuts
off the video feed and continue doing
the tick-tock video in another room back
to the make up these videos are usually
silly the first was still pretty creepy
wearing a whimsical onesie billy goat
starts the video and then jumps to
perform a dance but we can do
[Music]
just a second before disappearing again
science continues dancing and still
decided to post this young user performs
a fairly simple dance a wide smile on
her face while the app provides
background music to chance the breakfast
song groceries little disease young girl
no her video is about to end up in the
category of scary to top videos
that's the girl dances we can see a
portion of the house behind dude in the
back ends that's a top room this behind
is deemed one of the features of the
house visible behind there's an upstairs
hallway with a wooden banister and Riley
the hallways dark but that's the old
dances something unusual takes place
there Mel Gibson when is that felt like
a tick-tock creature we just don't know
about
it's like lower than the railing but
during its brief appearance we can
clearly see it's a human shape he's
completely dark looking too much like a
shadow for any features to become clear
these are its appearance he's
nonetheless terrifying these ghosts just
wanted and please make this viral on
Twitter and tick-tock
and say to the audience what do you
think this scary tick-tock video is
captured is it a prank for social media
fame I really captured something
paranormal I think it is especially
because of the way she phrased that
Twitter post it just sounds like yeah I
think it's great to that I mean the
first ones like it's hard to talk
especially with the dogs like you can't
just plan that Kenya man if you ever had
a dog or familiar without a way to
monetize my security guards employer got
pissed in the first video the security
guard station near one of the cemeteries
mausoleums when he hears a strange noise
he stays that it sounds like banging so
he most likely believes that he's
dealing with the trespasser ok deciding
that it's his job to investigate the
sound
[Music]
[Laughter]
no oh no that's Oh No
okay that on this side the camera a
blood-curdling scream inside the chapel
it seems to be screaming get out
[Music]
Rosi environment
unfortunately the childlike voice that
terrified in the night before has not
left the building
inside the voice greets him with a
hello' what's so scary he attends to
locate the child asking questions source
the video ends shortly after leaving
viewers to wonder what happened to the
God many believes that he quit his job
life to the hemorrhoid not depicted in
the footage but he this is left users
with more questions that is so scary
that is so scary they get out okay hey
I'm subscribed now that was pretty scary
yeah in fact of all the lists of scary
footage I've seen and I think that had
the highest quotient of convincingly
eerie like I wasn't sitting there
thinking too hard like okay you could
doctor like there was maybe one in here
where I was like I I'm very suspect of
this but the rest of them were just so
eerie in and of themselves that I wasn't
even thinking about though I mean for me
it's like the first one is the first and
last one that are the scariest ones to
me that first one with the dogs like I I
couldn't even tell like what like what
are they pointing out exactly I mean
looking at they had to slow it down and
really reference what it was so I could
get what they would slapped hand was
pointing at the fact that the dogs were
noticing it yeah and she had to take a
second to can any of these be faked sure
yeah okay let's just get that out of the
way explainable some other way but that
first one especially with the dogs
that's the thing that has me going the
most I mean that's what doctor strange
things you're like what is it boy you
know you find that weird thing yeah then
you start to think to yourself like well
if this was you know somebody creating a
prank video well if they had somebody
who already lives at that house or who
the dogs are familiar with and they
probably wouldn't have reacted yeah
something weird was going on and so it
does tickle your brain in that way and
also I feel like some of these types of
videos you can look at you can think
okay like in the fourth video the
framing I was like yeah that upstairs is
like it's made sure to be a frame where
is the first one like the lighting in
that hall isn't very good there's not a
lot that you can point out and go oh I
bet this is there there
give a shadow among other shadows in the
way it moves
yeah just like kind of as if it's been
caught and try to get out of yeah yeah
that's orb back in it yeah it's just
that that really keen eye really creeped
me out a lot yeah and it's it's small
enough that it doesn't look like it's
trying to call attention to something
like you can so easily miss it there's
two here where it's like girls dancing
and then something occurs in the
background it's similar the first one
where the girls in the kitchen I could
actually kind of buy that like it felt
up that I've seen a lot of ghost videos
where it's usually there's every one of
the lists usually has something like
that or some weird strange ambiguous
shape shadowy kind of transparent thing
passes by in the background yeah I mean
the fact that she didn't notice it at
all and in fact she's just like kept
dancing
it wasn't like let's just do some subtle
dance like she was going like goofier as
a Camco yeah exactly and it doesn't seem
like she was able to catch it on some
weather or anything like that but the
one that chance of rav4 Acamas it on I
don't buy it it feels like Internet fun
especially because she's like I want
this to go viral you know yeah Brandi
that's most people I'll take topic of
course we do YouTube of course we want
stuff to go popular really now the way
it was posted up like this has to go
viral that you seem like yeah this could
this could be a doctor but I mean the
makeup tutorial one I thought was also
really creepy because even if again like
there are ways you can open a closet
door or screw with lights
she really sold it if it's fake and it
didn't come across fake well the makeup
girls that a lot of makeup girls are
actresses I mean I don't know if she is
one but regardless every beat she hit
just seems so believable there she's so
terrific okay that's like little things
that yeah like little involuntary noises
that that are especially hard I think to
recreate in prank form
yeah I got a sidestep here and point out
the way slap hand assembles these videos
usually from list videos you kind of
just watch the whole thing play out then
you break it down and he's kind of like
a beat will happen and then he'll start
narrating and then another beat and it's
like he's doing this some storytelling
yeah with it which makes it even scarier
as he's walking you through it
it's unfolding before your eyes
sometimes you know they they play at
first and then he starts talking over it
but the way how a lot of these were
constructed yeah I actually really
admired like okay you're watching now if
you look in the background like the way
he did it really appreciate the script
that he composes them the way he chooses
to present each one of these he's gonna
walking you through them and then using
each little beat yeah thing to lead to
the next way to increase that tension
yeah but as far as the makeup girl goes
that's like a really hard one to fake
it's all done right above you the door
opening and closing the door the light
inside the closet
that's just like a super windy in the
know a giraffe was doing all that and
making your electricity go out it's the
only real logical explanation I could
possibly provide or something like that
because I mean the closet even has a lot
of shelving and stuff inside of it that
you can't get behind or cram you're
exactly - unless she had somebody like
on the bottom or behind her but still I
mean with the light it's a really hard
thing up ative it's really accurate the
thing is - that I find fascinating about
it is these people their videos are not
based around these things you know what
I mean a lot of times are these ghost
videos it's like Oh security camera
footage at some creepy place ghost
hunting going to an abandoned building I
gathered for they've want to get views
this is what they do but these are like
dancin makeup video random to show at
home just random user with their dogs
you know like his videos aren't based
around being scary the users accounts
they're just like a makeup tutorial but
it's very specific market instead of
thorough random scary video is not
exactly the way to galvanize that
company her brand yeah might draw some
attention and someone might be like wish
you might have some good bacon videos -
big crossover and diagram that last one
is very unsettling cuz when is started
off and then you see the kid I was like
al-kitabi what that because I was still
getting used to the structure how he
presents his videos yeah I thought that
was the end of it like he's just a kid
he had his work that as it kept going
though and the fact that it went into
the morning and the Mendes sound was
there could it be fake this all be
staged and doctored and maybe that's why
the videos are
there because he got fired for putting
in value working in a cemetery might
have been that right even might for all
we know there's that one side of like
well maybe he was putting this whole
thing together and he got discovered and
fired from it but hey I mean you could
have a promise it's like what the voices
the kids the flickering light of the
building and then coming back in the
mutually it's it's over that one night
never heard it again but to come back in
the morning hear the voice that just is
an extra punch of something really scary
and where you're at - and the voice of
like oh that is very creepy and and it
was a morgue right yeah it's like a
mausoleum or something in like a little
chapel area so concentration of the dead
boy
poor guy yeah watch I have more slap
hands videos if you don't subscribe to
this guy's videos do it now because this
is well worth it I thought this was
great this is one of my favorite just
ghost video compilations we've won I
don't have a tick-tock account by
denison am I
my girlfriend was showing me one the
other day were these I think it was like
these guys went scavenger hunt at a
beach some random once set up and they
found this like bag and it smelled
really bad so they called the cops but
they weren't around for the uncovering
of the bag and then come to find out it
was that honey part it was a dead body
they didn't get it on camera because
they were they were asked to leave but
they later follow it up and found out
there was a death it was a dead body you
know and it's a witch beach I don't know
we gotta go we gotta go to that Beach
you're gonna find some bodies take talk
famous it's worth all about well which
one of these do you believe which one
scares you the most subscribers slap
hand subscribe the real rejects click
the notification bell I know this has
nothing to do with fandom like most of
our content omit this is some of the
most fun tickle your brain with nature's
wonders cuz every one of these before
filming always starts off with as might
be boring and then sort of like oh my
god
thank you guys I see a certain